la noticia está conocido mientras muchos
rusos dormían los primeros lotes de la
vacuna rusa contra el coronavirus
llamado sputnik 5 y han partido rumbo a
algunas regiones de rusia se trata de
una experiencia piloto para comprobar la
cadena de logística la red de
distribución y sobre todo para ir
preparando este amplio proceso de
vacunación de millones de rusos según
las autoridades rusas la vacuna ofrece
una inmunidad de en torno a dos años
los primeros en recibirla serán la
población de mayor riesgo
fundamentalmente los sanitarios y
también los profesores sin embargo
muchos rusos no están viviendo con
especial entusiasmo el proceso que ahora
comienza y según las estadísticas casi
la mitad de los rusos no tienen ninguna
intención de ponerse esta vacuna no
porque teman los efectos de la espuma y
5 sino porque creen que el riesgo del
coronavirus ha sido magnificado y
exagerado por los medios de comunicación
mientras tanto las autoridades rusas
aseguran que fuera del país hay mucho
interés en su vacuna en torno a 20
países están interesados en recibir mil
millones de dosis